detrás de estas Islas Al otro lado del
Golfo de Finlandia Rusia
la patria de gregory huyó al día
siguiente de la invasión a Ucrania y no
puede imaginar volver un día a su casa
el presidente Vladimir Putin dice que
los rusos como gregory son traidores
paniata
no entiendo por qué la gente que ha
abandonado su país es considerada
traidora Por no querer formar parte de
este gran crimen la mayoría de mis
amigos se esconden del ejército Y estoy
convencido de que nadie quiere
enlistarse para ir a hacer la guerra en
Ucrania
cientos de miles de rusos han huido de
su país gregory está convencido de que a
muchos más les gustaría marcharse pero
carecen de medios económicos o tienen
miedo de hacerlo flautista de profesión
gregory pudo tener un visado para
Finlandia para él su mujer y sus dos
hijos pequeños trabaja a tiempo parcial
en un taller de reparación de
instrumentos musicales y pronto lo hará
en el teatro de kotka
desarraigarse es menos difícil de lo
esperado
cañas
Claro que te sientes preocupado cuando
dices que eres un Ruso que vienes de
Moscú y que naciste en San Petersburgo
pero cuando explicamos nuestra situación
la gente nos entiende
su familia vive en este edificio de la
periferia de kotka gracias a su estatuto
de refugiado pueden albergarse aquí de
manera gratuita sus vecinos son personas
rusas pero también ucranianas y las
relaciones entre ellos son buenas todos
comparten el traumatismo
del exilio forzado a causa de la guerra
de Vladimir Putin en Ucrania